the president and i are absolutely
committed
to ensuring that our immigration system
is orderly
and humane we are seeing here in el paso
unaccompanied minors who i spent time
with
who are filled with optimism but they
are without their family
no no mrs vice president for the record
migrant children are not optimistic and
okay maybe you didn't catch that in
today's quick tour of the border patrol
facility
in el paso but if you traveled a few
miles further to fort bliss army base
you'd find that kids are so miserable in
their cages
some of them have been placed on suicide
watch in fact
dozens have been placed on suicide watch
this is according to reporting from cbs
news who says the following federal
officials became so concerned about
migrant teens harming themselves
that they banned pencils pins scissors
nail clippers and regular toothbrushes
inside tents
housing hundreds of children according
to an internal document workers at the
site said they were even instructed
to remove the metal nose clips from n95
face masks that does not sound like
optimism
here now former white house senior
advisor and america first legal founder
stephen miller stephen great to have you
on the program thank you so the report
from cbs news suggests that kids are
being held something like
60 days they're being held in migrant
facilities moved on from their initial
border patrol
facilities but 60 days and it's taking a
toll dozens of kids now
who are looking not just depressed but
looking into self-harm
what's going on here how does this get
resolved
the trump administration solved the
unaccompanied minor crisis
in a sustainable way through humane
repatriation
to aliens home countries that single act
ended most child trafficking on our
border
the new administration made a conscious
decision
over the objections of career officials
some of whom they've since terminated
they made a conscious deliberate
decision
to end the repatriation policy and
instead
they have long-term housing followed by
release to
unknown sponsors in many cases inside
the united states
that means it is open season on children
in latin america
because smugglers coyotes and
traffickers
can advertise you will successfully gain
entry into the united states
and desperate people make desperate
decisions i want to be very clear about
something
this is not a case of harris and biden
trying but failing to secure the border
this is the case of biden and harris
trying and succeeding in destroying the
border
only if you understand that can you
understand everything else
what is going on well i understand that
i do understand that stephen so help me
understand how unprepared they were for
this crisis so the reason apparently
that so many kids are being held for so
long
is their policy as you pointed out to
find sponsors here in the united states
has to go through hhs and has to have a
case manager
handle each and every one of those
children in finding a sponsor
they don't have enough case managers
they're not prepared they literally
can't put people
on the job to take care of these
children so why were they so
unprepared for something that i think
you're right about
they don't mind happening because
they're zealots
that's the simple answer to the question
look at
what you didn't hear senator harris say
or vice president harris my apology say
a single time today
she didn't say we the united states of
america are not going to tolerate
illegal entry into our country
if you try to come in illegally you'll
be repatriated and returned to your home
country
she didn't say that because they're
zealots their policies
are extreme and therefore everything and
everyone else are collateral damage they
didn't care is the answer
because it's cruel and it's heartless
but they don't
care and the reality is they were warned
by career law enforcement officials
throughout the transition
that this would happen if they put catch
and release into place
yeah but they just didn't mind really
quickly stephen i want to get you to
answer this question by the way i mean
the details of this
are are not worth glossing over they're
important
there are stories here of kids using
their government-issued id
cards to try to slit their own risks
this is a very
unhumanitarian situation these migrant
kids are finding themselves in take me
back to the trump administration really
quickly you said
you had a policy of repatriation you
took them back to their home countries
tell me how long that took stephen in
those individual cases perhaps on
average but also how's that done
is that not difficult to find where
those kids are coming from
i mean if they're unaccompanied and i
don't know if they're willingly giving
you that information where do you know
to send them back to
to their to their parents their
relatives their legal guardians in their
home countries and they willing
they willingly pass that on that
information absolutely and in fact
in fact so it's such an important
question we could do this sometimes
in less than 72 hours we could contact
the home consulate the home embassy
social workers and professionals in the
home country get them back to their
closest relative
their legal guardian and oftentimes
their parents in their home country
you talk about root causes the root
cause of the misery
the suffering the suicidal ideation the
terrible
monstrous things that are happening
right now is a decision
to nullify law enforcement to erase our
border
to engage in reckless extremist behavior
for an ideological objective
it's a stain on the conscience of this
nation what was done and it was
all deliberate every single piece of it
was purposeful
i encourage everyone to look into this
story it really is heartbreaking to find
out what's happening there with
children stephen miller thank you so
much for your time tonight thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else